and in other parts of the world and in
this country today a record-setting
storm system will deliver another day of
wet weather for tens of millions of
people on the East Coast this rain is no
joke heavy rains flooded roads and
parking lots in Maryland yesterday
Baltimore is having its second wettest
month on record the floodwaters swamped
homes in Pennsylvania residents there
face the threat of even more rain today
parts of in Sylvania have had more than
15 inches of rain since the storms began
six days ago
Baltimore and the surrounding area are
under flood warnings today DeMarco
Morgan in his isn't hard-hit Hershey
Pennsylvania
DeMarco good morning good morning guys
believe it or not this is a road right
here behind me that leads to a
subdivision called Union deposit now
many of those homes are covered in parts
of that area are covered in water their
Emergency Management says they have
conducted three dozen rescues and five
of the hardest hit counties in
Pennsylvania's Governor Tom wolf says he
will tour Schuylkill County that's an
area that suffered significant damage
parts of Pennsylvania remain underwater
as a relentless storm offers no rest for
waterlogged residents Pennsylvania's
Department of Transportation says 97
roads were closed as of Wednesday
afternoon views from high above showed
the pockets of flooding and swollen
waterways I was surprised how quick the
creeks came up and I'm just hoping it
goes down enough to absorb the next
storm that's coming in Hershey Park
remains closed today due to the weather
impact on roads and bridges leading into
the park just north Knoebels amusement
park also shut down after floodwaters
rushed into the complex as soon as we
get one thing cleaned up it seems like
something else goes down in Baltimore
County Maryland a break from the rain
means a rush to cleanup crews cut apart
massive trees that came loose from the
soaked ground and some of the crust
gates of the Conowingo Dam were open to
reduce water levels heavy rain pushed
through the ceiling of this restaurant
in Arlington Virginia no one was hurt
rescue crews in nearby Washington DC
were called when floodwaters watched
this mail truck off the road it was a
river it was a river back here but this
definitely has
put a damper on things at North
Carolina's Outer Banks they've even
started pumping the water out of the
roadway and into the ocean in an effort
to reduce the flooding back in
Pennsylvania a sinkhole in Palmyra is
making residents frustrated and
emotional it's very concerning I mean
we're in a neighborhood where it's just
happening and you just never know when
you're gonna wake up and have this in
your backyard we do want to point out
that the Red Cross has two shelters open
including one here in Hershey asked for
these for Tyler Creek right here behind
me it actually crushed it overnight but
won't go below flood stage until
sometime on Saturday when it comes to
rain you can expect for sometime next
week
Nora Wow DeMarco where you're standing
really gives a sense of that flooding
thank you so much